When you have a complex project,
it's important to approach it
one small piece at a time.
We don't recommend that you jump
straight into writing meme.
It's easier to experiment
if you create a temporary
X code project that you
don't plan on keeping.
To learn to pick images, for
example, you might want to create
a one button app that picks and
displays a single image,
the smallest possible project that will
let you learn what you need to know.
Baby steps to the meme generator.
So here I've made a simple
project to experiment with, and
since the meme editor has a toolbar
at the bottom of the screen,
I'm going to go ahead and
drag one of those in.
And I'll position it and
set its constraints.
The tool bar comes with this button,
but I'm going to go head and
change its label to pick.
And you see I've already got an image
view, so you can go head and
drag one of those in and
set its constraints.
Now I'm going to close this
outline view for a minute and
open up the assistant editor, and then
we can add an outlet for our image view.
Now, let's go down to our button, and
we'll add an action for our button.
Let's call it pickAnImage.
And that ought to do it for Storyboard.
So, we'll focus on our
view controller file.
I'm going to get rid of this
extra method for now, and
here in the pick and image method
that we just added, we want to launch
out UI image picker controller,
just like we did in lesson two.
So we add these two lines to present
the image picker and let's run it and
see how it looks.
And there we go.
We can choose from our outlets.
So we're making progress, but
when I choose a picture, I can't
really tell that it's being chosen.
We still need to implement
the delegate pattern, and
set our view controller as
the delegate of the image picker.
Next step, we'll investigate
the delegate protocol so
we'll know what method will be called
when the picker has an image chosen.